hey there
today i'm going to cover the impacts of
agricultural practices and to do so i'm
going to take you through my morning
ritual it sounds weird but my bowl of
multigrain cheerios and rice milk and
relaxing in my super comfy pajamas
they're all connected to intensive
agricultural practices
in particular tilling
slash and burn farming
and fertilizers
so let's take a closer look at the
cheerios in my bowl
most of my cereal here is actually
composed of grains like oats corn and
barley
and growing grains typically starts with
tilling and good quality soil with lots
of nutrients
but what is tilling in short tilling is
the process of turning soil and it's
really useful because loosening the soil
allows farmers to easily control weeds
and other pests at the surface of the
soil and it helps them to prepare the
soil for seeding
sometimes in areas that have been
heavily farmed the soil can become
compacted over time
here tilling can help to break down the
soil into smaller pieces called soil
aggregates and allow for easier crop
planting
now tillage has been done for thousands
of years but it's changed a lot from the
past when we used human labor and big
draft animals to till small fields
usually once per year nowadays in the
era of industrialized agriculture
large-scale farmers use heavy mechanized
equipment that can till thousands of
acres multiple times per year
okay we're growing more so we're tilling
more a lot more and while soil tillage
can help to loosen and aerate soil what
do you think happens when heavy
machinery passes over the land and tears
up the surface multiple times per year
this practice of repeated intensive
tilling compacts the lower layers of the
soil and loosens the topsoil to the
point that it loses the ability to hold
water and nutrients in place
tillage also reduces any leftover crop
residue like plant stocks so in turn the
exposed soil service becomes really
vulnerable to wind and rain because
nothing is really holding the soil down
or providing cover
so what happens next
loose soil can start to collect in
surface runoff and become displaced
through erosion
when this happens soil organic matter
and nutrients are literally washed or
blown away
who would have thought that these
cheerios were doing so much damage
but there's some good news here too
low-till or no-till farming alternatives
can alleviate some of these problems
thankfully
in the palouse a huge agricultural area
in the western u.s where a lot of grains
just like the ones in my cereal are
grown no-till farming is really
important because the fields are
well
they're really steep and hilly and wind
and rain can cause a lot of erosion when
the soil is heavily tilled
by not tilling the fields farmers can
prevent soil erosion and
more importantly from my perspective
make sure that they can grow lots of
grains for my cheerios
but wait cereal isn't complete without
milk
now i personally like rice milk because
i'm lactose sensitive and rice is
commonly grown in temperate and tropical
regions oftentimes in areas where soil
quality isn't the best and nutrients are
lacking
so
how do farmers get nutrients back into
the soil and more importantly how do
they grow rice for my rice milk at
breakfast
well they often use slash and burn
farming
so like the name forest plots are
slashed or cut left to dry and then
burned the ash left over from the
burning fertilizes the soil but it's
only a temporary benefit
after about three to five years the
productivity of slashed and burned plots
goes down really quickly due to the loss
of nutrients and as weeds start to grow
again
when this happens farmers simply abandon
the field move over to a new area and
repeat the process
but it can take decades for these plots
to recover once they've been slashed
burned and farmed and this practice can
become a vicious cycle
in the amazon for example people in
rural areas rely on slash and burn so
that they can make money selling the
crops they grow or create open pastures
for animals to graze
in the process thousands of acres are
burned each year and as these trees and
plants burn enormous amounts of
greenhouse gases mainly carbon dioxide
are produced which contribute to climate
change
and sometimes too fires may not be well
managed and can burn out of control
causing huge costly wildfires
but it's not all doom and gloom when it
comes to my tasty rice milk there are
alternatives to slash and burn which
include applying animal fertilizer like
manure on used plots to bring nutrients
back to the soil or using alley cropping
in which trees or other vegetation are
planted between crops to help keep
nutrients and moisture in the soil
all right by now i've eaten my breakfast
and i'm relaxing in my super comfy
cotton pajamas but turns out that cotton
is actually a really finicky crop to
grow and it requires a lot of
fertilizers
and fertilizers help plants grow but
that's not a bad thing right
and it's not in fact we've been using
fertilizers for millennia for thousands
of years people have used natural
fertilizers to replenish or increase
nutrients in the soil and promote plant
growth natural fertilizers meant that
farmers used things like leftover crops
manure wood ash ground bones fish or
fish parts and even bird and bat poop
in the early 1800s though scientists
discovered that nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium were key to plant growth and
in time many farmers began to switch
from natural fertilizers to artificial
fertilizers with higher concentrations
of these nutrients which greatly
increased crop yields in other words
farmers could grow more and that means
more cotton and more comfy pajamas
but there's a catch
now that farmers are growing more crops
than any time in history we've learned
that there are impacts to using large
amounts of very concentrated fertilizers
applying too much fertilizer can pollute
runoff water with excess fertilizer and
pollute local surface waters
as nutrient-rich materials like
fertilizer make their way into nearby
rivers lakes and oceans they can cause
major problems in the balance of
nutrients in marine ecosystems
when too many nutrients from fertilizers
saturate a body of water called
eutrophication these nutrients feed the
rapid growth of algae in turn these
massive algae blooms can suck up all the
oxygen and bodies of water and lead to
enormous fish die-offs called dead zones
quite a morbid situation and very
different from the happy unicorns of my
pajamas
but there's ways to reduce the amount of
fertilizers released into waterways
farmers can limit the amount of
fertilizer that they apply or use
compost which is decomposed organic
material as a fertilizer which tends to
have lower and safer levels of nitrates
and phosphates
and there you have it common
agricultural practices and their impacts
in a nutshell or really a bowl of cereal